according to richard delgado and gene
stefanczyk are some of the founders of
critical race theory critical race
theory essentially holds four basic
tenets tenant number one is that racism
is ordinary not aberrational it is the
way that societies are direct quotes
this is the usual way society does
business the common everyday experience
of most people of color in this country
second that these systems of oppression
serve quote important purposes both
psychic and material for the dominant
group namely white americans
third that race and races are the
product of social thoughts and relations
so all groupings are essentially
arbitrary but they're created by white
people to harm other people and finally
that minority status quote brings with
it a presumed competence to speak about
race and racism meaning that if you're a
person of color you get to speak about
race and racism and nobody else does
okay when you take that together what
that really means is that all inequality
is inequity
it means any discrepancy can be chalked
up to systemic racism without ever
having to explain how the discrepancy
occurred
you never have to actually point to a
problematic policy in order to explain
why the discrepancy exists you just
point to the discrepancy and this in and
of itself means that all the
institutions are bad
right everything good is fruit of the
poison is free all those institutions
were built by rich white men who are
seeking to enshrine their own racism in
the way the institutions work
right boiled down into lesson one's form
crt sounds precisely like ebermex candy
okay and this is a way of reducing risk
in how you think about yourself it's a
way of reducing your mental risk
now here is the thing
our version to risk obviously it applies
across the board it applies to finance
we we outsource nearly all policy to the
federal reserve at this point we have a
cadre of experts who are supposed to
decide how much your dollar is worth and
also keep down unemployment we outsource
all coveted policy to supposed experts
who happen to screw it up six ways from
sunday well maybe funding gain of
function research in wuhan
[Music]
all these experts fail and that failure
makes us angry because we have been lied
to we've been told we can hand over
everything to the experts and they will
push a magic button and they will fix
everything
but but they're lying to us that's not
the case
and when they fail they have two
alternatives they can admit it or they
can get us to turn on each other and so
when the experts have promised us they
will mitigate all risks when that
doesn't work instead they blame you they
blame tell you to blame your neighbor
it's your neighbor who's standing in our
way
and so my call today is when you get
beyond the coddling what you realize is
that the coddling in the end is a shield
for people in power to never have to be
answerable
if they can promise you that they will
mitigate all your risks even if they
fail they will just blame the person
sitting next to you if you go along with
them you'll give them more power and
more power and more power but you won't
lead a fulfilled life
we actually have to re-embrace risk on a
personal level and on a societal level
we have to take the risk of freely
exchanging ideas because that's where
innovation happens we have to take the
risk of being able to invest and reap
the benefits of that risk
we have to take the risks of for example
in our personal relationship in a
personal relationship getting married is
a risk it is foregoing a current benefit
for a future game right you are you are
foreclosing all sorts of other
possibilities because you have chosen to
make a life with this one person that is
a risk marriage is a risk having kids is
a risk you don't know what they're going
to turn out like
right you really don't
and it does vary day to day on what you
think the trajectory looks like
but the thing is that those risks make
life worth living
the risk might pay off or maybe you fail
and you learn something more deep about
yourself maybe you learn from the
failure and you do better the next time
or maybe it's just that you've
strengthened your own character because
you've made free choices in a free way
which is what makes us human in the end
every decision you make is a risk
the biggest risk of all of course is the
decision to be free and to take
responsibility for your own choices
that's a major risk but if you take that
risk you become a better and a stronger
human being a more contributing human
being a more valuable human being you
feel better about yourself
when we discard risk we discard meaning
when we are coddled we discard our own
ability to be a fully adult human being
and here's the here's the dirty little
secret no matter how much we try to
discard the risk no matter how much we
try to set up institutions that mitigate
against the risk no matter how many
boxes we draw against the people who sit
next to us in society hoping that this
will mitigate our risk
you can't actually discard risk
it's inevitable because reality entails
risk just as it always did just as when
we were lizard brains wandering in the
jungle there's risk now too and we can
build dams against the risk and the
waters can pile up behind those dams and
then eventually they will blow right
through the dam and when that risk
materializes it'll be a lot bigger and a
lot worse than the tiny risks that we
have been avoiding all the way along
this process
when that damn burst it destroys
civilizations small risks can be
channeled small risks can be withstood
when you build up entire bulwarks and
edifices of holding back risk and then
the risk materializes it swamps
everything
it's a huge civilizational mistake
reality always wins in the end in fact i
root for reality because when you root
for reality you're rooting for people to
learn how to deal with reality which
again is how we lead fulfilled lives so
we can all do that we can choose to live
free rather than coddled it'll make us
better people more open people more
understanding people
and when we do that i think that not
only will we be saving the country and
saving the civilization we'll be saving
ourselves